je sais j'ai appris au bout de deux ans
quand même j'ai 26 ans pas 48 des
regarder ou pour un truc de ouf
on dirait que j'ai chargé de pièces non
c'est juste une transition comme pour
les jeunes
aussi enfin il bel atout
[Rires]
en 1982 jack lang a donc organisé pour
la première fois en france la fête de la
musique un 21 juin la nuit la plus
courte de l'année il faut savoir que
nulle part sur la planète ça existait et
que depuis énormément et nombre de pays
ont enchaîné là dessus et ont repris la
même idée je trouve que pour une fois
c'est une idée française qui gérait 20
ans tout beaucoup parce qu'on est dans
paris et c'est un beau boxon pour rouler
parce que tout le monde s'installe donc
en 92 c'était beaucoup moins organisés
et s'étaient beaucoup plus bordélique
mais c'était absolument charmant moi je
descendais que ma guitare et mon ampli
au bas de chez moi on joue avec les
voisins tu pourrais miettes et cuillères
et jouer de la musique cajun tu pourras
mietton saxophone ta petite batterie ce
que tu voulais et j'aimais beaucoup ça
[Musique]
mam qu'est ce que tu fais
tu fais quoi manger
je pense que c'est renier mes mamans
mais maman laisse moi voir
laisse-moi goûter c'est quoi
ma surprise quand on a des surprises à
manger on a semblé très surpris c'est
toujours là c'est vrai
[Musique]
alice qui préfèrent faire un câlin à
papa ou maman ah là là
et qui préfère faire un câlin un arbre
on va papa
qui préfèrent faire un canal du ce ou à
papa
je vais faire bouger